Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field, the principles can work for you.
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的内容之前，我想先告诉大家一个令人兴奋的消息。如果你曾想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“循环收入竞赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这项挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是准心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，这些原则都同样适用。
There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode.
此外，还有机会赢取由Lisa亲自提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的内容吧。
If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Mary Entrance It's so greatly appreciated. What we're going to talk to you about today is thinking about, so I've got my first kind of relevant experience post, and it might be that you have got like an assistant psychologist post or, you know, research assistant post or something else which feels like, you know, the next step that you've been striving for. And then you're like, so now what, you know, what do I do now? Now I've got to where I wanted to be. And if you're listening to this and you're thinking, well, this isn't anywhere near where I am right now. You know, perhaps you're a psychology student or a psychology undergraduate and you're thinking, well, you know, I'll tune out because it's not for me. I would say listen still because it can still be super useful to think about covering these bases before you get there. And, you know, I think this is stuff that I would have wished that I knew before I got there.
如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这成为你的指南吧。欢迎收听《准心理学家播客》，我是Marianne Trent博士。非常感谢大家的收听。今天我们要讨论的是关于你获得第一份相关工作后的心态。这可能是一份助理心理学家职位、研究助理职位，或者其他你一直努力争取并感觉是下一步的工作。然后你会想：“现在该怎么办？我已经达到了我想要的目标。”如果你正在听这段话，并觉得“这离我现在的处境还很远”，比如你可能还是一名心理学本科生，觉得“这不适合我，我还是关掉吧”，我会建议你继续听下去，因为在达到目标之前提前了解这些基础知识是非常有用的。我想，如果我在入行前就知道这些，那该多好。
So I hope you will still find it really useful, too. And it's all part of the process. You know, it will be your time and it will come and good things will happen but we have to kind of you know do the bits below to build our knowledge and our skills and our experience and to build our readiness for it for that and our ability to be able to talk confidently about what we're doing and why so yeah I hope that you will find this really useful. So maybe this new job or new post offer feels like a really exciting, you know, tangible step. And I remember when I was, I'd just done my GCSEs and I got my GCSE results and I felt like, oh, okay, finally I've got something that kind of helps me put my abilities and my confidence kind of under my belt a little bit you know kind of proof that I know what I'm doing and I'm doing all right
所以我希望你也能从中受益。这一切都是过程的一部分。你的时间终会到来，好事也会发生，但我们必须打好基础，积累知识、技能和经验，为未来做好准备，并能够自信地谈论我们在做什么以及为什么这样做。所以，我希望你会觉得这很有用。也许这份新工作或新职位让你觉得是一个令人兴奋的、切实的进步。我记得我刚考完GCSE并拿到成绩时，感觉终于有了一些东西能证明我的能力，让我更有信心，证明我所做的一切都是对的。
and for me those GCSE results felt like the first kind of thing, you know, that proved that, that demonstrated that. And, you know, my first assistant psychologist post felt similar, you know, it was a sign to myself and to the world and others outside. Oh, you know, she's, I'm, she's heading, you know, towards that goal. And that's tangible proof that actually this isn't all futile. So yeah, I hope you find that as a useful way of thinking about that, because I certainly did. And I know I said either in there, I think it was the first episode of the podcast, you know, that people might say, Oh, you don't get it. You know, why don't you go off and do something different? Like be, you know, a buyer for Argos or whatever it was I was doing at the time they just didn't they didn't get why this was so important to me they didn't get why I was you know so upset that I couldn't find even any
对我来说，那些GCSE成绩是第一件证明我能力的事情。我的第一份助理心理学家工作也有类似的感觉，它向我自己、向世界、向外界证明：“看，她正在朝着那个目标前进。”这是切实的证据，证明这一切并非徒劳。所以，我希望你也能这样看待它，因为我确实是这样想的。我记得在播客的第一集里说过，人们可能会说：“你不明白，为什么不去干点别的？比如去Argos当采购员之类的。”他们不明白为什么这对我如此重要，也不明白为什么我找不到助理心理学家职位时会那么难过。
you know assistant psychologist posts to apply for and when I did you know why I was so distressed when they were closing before I'd even got home from work to apply for them. So, yeah, you know, you're allowed to be on your own team, even if those around you don't get it. You always need to be on your own team. And, you know, we do doubt ourselves as humans. It's part of our incredibly tricky brains. But, you know, you're allowed to have that self-belief and that self-importance about why you're doing it. And that hopefully with, you know, the requisite stripes that you earn along your path, you know, you'll get there.
当我申请时，为什么在还没下班回家前职位就关闭了，我会感到那么沮丧。所以，即使周围的人不理解，你也要站在自己这一边。你永远需要支持自己。作为人类，我们确实会自我怀疑，这是我们大脑复杂机制的一部分。但你要允许自己拥有那种自信，并重视你所做的事情。希望随着你沿途获得的必要成就，你终会到达目的地。
Good things will happen for you. But, yeah, be on your own team, even if those around you are giving you kind of disharmony. You know, they're not singing in unison with you. They might be singing a completely different tune. And that's OK. You're allowed to sing your own tune. And when I think about, you know, my other jobs that I've had in the past, yeah, you know, they would have sustained me and fulfilled me for a time. But really, you know, to quote Princess Poppy, they just weren't my jam. You know, they didn't ignite and enliven me and they weren't, they weren't a bit of me. And so it's okay to keep striving for the stuff that feels authentic, that feels like it is going to light
好事会发生在你身上。但请记住，即使周围的人与你步调不一致，甚至发出不和谐的声音，你也要支持自己。他们可能唱着完全不同的调子，那没关系，你可以唱自己的歌。回想我过去做过的其他工作，它们确实在一段时间内维持了我的生活并满足了我的需求，但引用《魔发精灵》里波比公主的话，它们“不是我的菜”。它们没有点燃我、激发我，它们不属于我。所以，坚持追求那些让你感到真实、让你感到振奋的事情是没问题的。
you up. Because even though I love my job, I love what I do, there are still some days where I'd rather, you know, just sit around and watch Netflix. But on the whole, you know, actually, I'm really excited when I wake up and I realize it's a Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday or Friday. I'm like, oh, yeah, I get to do my business today. I get to do the stuff I love and I get to see clients, you know, and I've got quite a nice balance that Mondays and Fridays are days where I do just stuff for my business development or stuff in the background. And sometimes I don't do anything at all. You know, I went off recently to a Van Gogh exhibition on a Friday and had lunch, which was really nice. Last week, I had my hair done on a Friday. And today I speak to you on a
因为即使我热爱我的工作，热爱我所做的一切，有时我还是想坐着看Netflix。但总的来说，当我醒来意识到是周一到周五时，我真的很兴奋。我会想：“太棒了，今天我可以经营我的事业，做我热爱的事情，见我的客户。”我的时间安排很平衡，周一和周五是我处理业务发展或后台工作的日子。有时我甚至什么都不做。最近的一个周五，我去看了一场梵高展览，还吃了午餐，非常愉快。上周五，我去做了头发。今天也是周五，我正在录制播客。
Friday as I'm recording podcast episodes. So I've managed to stack my week and organize it so that I've got a bit more breathing space on a Monday and a Friday. And, you know, you might be hearing that thinking, oh, it's okay for you. You know, I can't do that in the service I'm working in. And, you know, I hear you. I've been there. I've been there for sure. I hope that, you know, your experiences along the way and, you know, everything that you're doing and everything you're hearing from me, hopefully, helps you build confidence and a belief that you can build a career for yourself that feels really energizing and that feels really exciting and that allows you to be your authentic self. So, you know, some of the early feedback I've had from this podcast and certainly someone
所以我设法调整了我的周计划，让周一和周五有更多的喘息空间。你听了可能会想：“这对你来说当然容易，我在我工作的部门可做不到。”我理解你，我曾经也经历过。我希望你一路走来的经历，以及你从我这里听到的一切，能帮助你建立自信，相信你可以为自己打造一份充满活力、令人兴奋的职业，让你能够展现真实的自我。我从这个播客中收到了一些早期的反馈，还有我之前谈到的一场大学演讲，对方说：“我们邀请你是因为我们喜欢你展现真实自我的方式，以及你说话的自然感。”
I was speaking to earlier about a university presentation that I'm going to be doing, you know, she said, well, we've asked you to do it because we like how, you know, how OK you are with being yourself and how naturally you talk. So I hope you find that to be the case too, and that you can lean in to your own abilities, to be authentic to yourself. You're enough, you know, and what you've got to say and the way you think about the world is important and valid. This is quite a long introduction to this, isn't it? You know, but it's all relevant. You know, I've got to I've got to boost you out and send you out there into the world to do these really good things. And, you know, I know I've got a lot of strings to my bow currently, but I feel like, you know, everything I do and everything I've got is underpinned by my core foundations, you know, my experiences as a qualified psychologist. carry with me each individual client session, each individual supervision session, and each
所以我希望你也能发现这一点，并能够依靠自己的能力，保持真实。你已经足够好了，你的想法和你看待世界的方式都很重要且有价值。这段开场白有点长，对吧？但这一切都是相关的。我必须鼓励你，把你推向世界去完成那些伟大的事情。我知道我现在身兼数职，但我感觉我所做的一切都建立在我的核心基础之上，即我作为一名合格心理学家的经验。我带着这些经验参加每一次客户咨询、每一次督导会议和每一次讲座，因为这就是我们作为临床医生随着时间推移而成长的方式。
individual lecture I've been to, you know, because of the way that we build over time as clinicians. I'm multi-layered, you know, and I'm, you know, I'm built of a lot of the words of others and the experience of others. And I'm pretty fortunate that, you know, on the whole, hearing to think about whether actually what they're asking of you is reasonable, what their opinions of you are, you know, are based on actual facts and not just their own, you know, beliefs and opinions. So, yeah, tune into what you're thinking about what you're doing and just listen to, you know, whether whether the feedback you're getting, if it's not great, is feeling like it's coming from a place that's trying to help you be different or better, whether it's kind of constructive feedback. So well done, you. You've got this job. you've got this job that you've really, really been excited for. So, you know, you've had the moment of seeing the job advert or hearing about it for the first time. And you just, you know, you read it and you think, that's it, that's my job. That's happening, that's happening for me. And I got that when I applied for my first assistant post that I did get,
我是多层次的，我由他人的言语和经验构建而成。我很幸运，总的来说，我会思考别人对你的要求是否合理，他们对你的评价是否基于事实，而不是仅仅基于他们自己的信念和观点。所以，关注你的想法，听听你得到的反馈，如果反馈不佳，看看它是否来自一个试图帮助你变得不同或更好的人，看看它是否是建设性的反馈。做得好，你得到了这份工作。你得到了那份让你非常兴奋的工作。你经历了看到招聘广告或第一次听说它的时刻，你读了它，然后想：“就是它，这是我的工作。它正在发生，它属于我。”当我申请第一份助理职位并成功时，我就是这种感觉。
believe me, I applied for a fair few. I didn't even get interviewed for. So, um, but yeah, the one I got, um, you know, I saw, yeah, this is it. You know, I am ready for this. This is mine. And the same with my, um, second assistant paid post. Um, I just saw it and I was like, that's mine. That is my job and I'm coming for it. And nothing is stopping me. I'm just going to be relentless about it. This is my job. Whereas in contrast for my first qualified job,
相信我，我申请过不少职位，甚至连面试机会都没得到。但那份我成功拿下的工作，我当时就觉得：“就是它，我已经准备好了，这是我的。”我的第二份助理职位也是如此，我看到它就觉得：“那是我的，那是我的工作，我志在必得。”没有什么能阻止我，我会坚持不懈。这是我的工作。相比之下，我的第一份正式工作，
yeah, I just, I'm really excited about the opportunity. But there were so few jobs at the time that I don't know if I actually would have ended up working in CAMHS if it hadn't just been that they, you know, they offered me the job, but it ended up working out completely beautifully for my first four years of qualified. So, you know, you've got this job, you've got the job offer, perhaps you're waiting out your notice at your old job and those can be slow and painful weeks. But you know, maybe you're listening to this, you know, about to start your new job, or maybe you're, you know, you haven't got a job at the moment and you're going to your dream job or next job. And you're like, so now what? So I thought it'd be really useful to tell you about some of the things that I've done ahead of, you know, chunks in a week off of unpaid leave in between my jobs. And that might not be achievable for you, you know, depending on your circumstances. But for me, it always feels like a little bit of golden time, you know, to be able to have a little rest and a
我确实对这个机会感到非常兴奋。但当时的工作岗位太少了，如果不是他们录用了我，我不知道我最终是否会进入儿童与青少年心理健康服务（CAMHS）工作。但结果证明，这对我作为合格心理学家的前四年来说非常完美。所以，你得到了这份工作，你拿到了录用通知，也许你正在等待旧工作的离职通知期结束，那可能是缓慢而痛苦的几周。但也许你正在听这个节目，准备开始新工作，或者你目前还没有工作，正在奔向你的梦想职位。你可能会想：“现在该怎么办？”所以我认为分享一些我在工作间隙休无薪假时做的事情会很有用。
little recharge and to help me transition from one stage of my life to the next. And I actually went away with my mum. We went away to Spain for a few days and rented an apartment there with a pool. And, you know, we were eating nice food and having some sunshine and, you know, reading and, you know, having some naps, you know, long lines and things. And that was a really nice way for me to be able to go from a relevant job, but not under a qualified psychologist to my first assistant psychologist post under a clinical psychologist, it felt like the big real deal. But I also absolutely had this pressure of, oh, what enough? What, what, what, what? Am I enough? Can this, you know, can I really do this? You know, I've told them I can. And so I did lean into the pressure to feel like I knew a little bit about what I was doing. And so I did ask my
这可能不适合你，取决于你的具体情况。但对我来说，这总感觉是一段黄金时间，让我能够休息和充电，帮助我从人生的一个阶段过渡到下一个阶段。我实际上和妈妈一起去西班牙度假了几天，租了一间带游泳池的公寓。我们吃着美食，享受阳光，阅读，小睡。这对我来说是一个非常好的过渡方式，让我从一份非合格心理学家的相关工作，过渡到在临床心理学家指导下的第一份助理心理学家工作，这感觉像是真正的大事。但我确实也感到了压力：“我够格吗？我真的能做到吗？”我告诉他们我可以，所以我确实利用了这种压力，让自己感觉对工作有所了解。
soon-to-be supervisor whether there was any reading recommended. And I believe she would have recommended, you know, a forensic older adult book or something along those lines or working with an inpatient population. So I did read that from my sun lounger just to feel like I was getting myself versed in, you know, the right conversations even in my head, you know, the right language to be using to talk about those things. So that might be something that you feel like would be useful. But also know that you are enough. You know, they have they've offered you the job because you're the best person for the job, you know, with your knowledge, skills and experience. So, you know, do know that you you are enough, you know. And actually, I think with retrospect, with hindsight, what I realize is that probably what I was wanting was to walk into that
所以我问我未来的主管是否有推荐的阅读材料。我相信她推荐了一本关于法医老年人心理学或类似主题的书，或者是关于住院患者工作的书。所以我躺在躺椅上读了那本书，只是为了让自己感觉在谈话中——甚至在脑海中——能使用正确的语言。这可能对你也有用。但也要知道，你已经足够好了。他们录用你是因为你是这份工作的最佳人选，拥有相应的知识、技能和经验。所以，请相信你已经足够好了。回想起来，我意识到我当时可能只是想在第一天上班时就感觉自己已经工作了六个月。但那是不现实的。
job on day one and feel like I'd been there six months. But that's not realistic. You know, all of us need time to grow into new roles. And, you know, we're going to be different to others, you know, so it might be that they're taking on someone else new in your team at the same time. And that was certainly the case for me. My friend, well, she's now a friend. I didn't know her before. But we both were offered a job at the same time in the same service. And yeah, you know, we're different clinicians and we were there then.
我们都需要时间来适应新角色。我们每个人都不同，可能团队里同时录用了其他人，我当时就是这样。我的朋友——她现在是我的朋友，当时我不认识她——我们同时被同一部门录用了。我们是不同的临床医生，当时我们都在那里。
And that has to be OK. You know, we can't necessarily be comparing ourselves to other people in the team or the service because that's just not gonna you know it's not gonna lead to happy outcomes for us because you need to be your genuine self and they've obviously offered the job to you and so you know well done you so I always think it's also quite nice to mark um to mark these achievements tangibly and my husband always says you're not a dog you don't need a treat and I'm like yes I do yes I do so it might not be food related but you know it might be that um you know I buy myself some new clothes to match this milestone in my life. So I definitely had like an assistant
这必须是可以接受的。我们不一定非要拿自己和团队里的其他人比较，因为那不会带来快乐的结果。你需要做真实的自己，他们显然是录用了你，所以做得好。我一直认为，用切实的方式来标记这些成就是很好的。我丈夫总是说：“你又不是狗，不需要奖励。”我说：“不，我需要，我真的需要。”这可能与食物无关，但我可能会给自己买些新衣服来纪念人生的这个里程碑。我确实有一个“助理心理学家衣橱”。说实话，有些衣服现在还在。
psychologist wardrobe. Some of them are still around now, I won't lie. And, you know, a pair of shoes that I could look down at my feet if I was feeling like I was floundering and think, oh, yes, yes, I am an assistant psychologist because I'm wearing my assistant psychologist shoes. So that might be useful for you as well to feel like you're wearing your, you know, significant job uniform. And, you know, I still I still treat myself like a dog. Now, you know, when I sold the first I decided in my head a batch number of how many our tricky brain kits it would take. And then I'd celebrate by buying myself a nice perfume that I'd wanted for a while. So I definitely rewarded myself like a dog then.
还有一双鞋，如果我感到迷茫，低头看看脚，就会想：“哦，是的，我是助理心理学家，因为我穿着我的助理心理学家鞋。”这可能对你也有用，让你感觉穿上了你的“重要工作制服”。我现在依然像对待狗一样奖励自己。当我卖出第一批“棘手大脑工具包”时，我在心里设定了一个数字，然后通过给自己买一瓶我心仪已久的香水来庆祝。那时我确实像奖励狗一样奖励了自己。
And you might find it helpful to have, you know, a new perfume or fragrance in your life as well to, you know, signify, you know, I'm an assistant psychologist now. I'm a research assistant. This is the fragrance I wear to celebrate and mark where I am right now. And also know that all of us sometimes sit at our desk and think, I don't know what I'm doing. And it's that case of the imposter syndrome showing up. And I'm just thinking now about a resource that shows, you know, I think it's our levels of danger as we go forward in our careers. So to begin with,
你可能会发现，生活中有一款新的香水或香氛来标志“我现在是一名助理心理学家”或“我现在是一名研究助理”也很有帮助。这是我用来庆祝和标记我目前所处位置的香氛。还要知道，我们所有人有时坐在办公桌前都会想：“我不知道自己在做什么。”这就是冒名顶替综合症在作祟。我正在想一个资源，展示我们在职业生涯中前进时的危险等级。起初，
we feel like we know absolutely loads and we'll tell anybody who listens about it. And then as we go forward in time, we realize how little we know and that's when our imposter syndrome sets in so what I'll do is I'll tidy up what I've just said and put it into a resource that you can download so the details of that will be through the show notes so check that out if that sounds like that would be useful for you and I would say as you go forward in your career it's always OK to not know, you know,
我们觉得自己知道得很多，并会告诉任何愿意听的人。然后随着时间的推移，我们意识到自己知道得有多么少，这就是冒名顶替综合症开始的时候。所以我会整理一下我刚才说的话，把它做成一个你可以下载的资源，详细信息会在节目说明中，如果这对你有用，请查看。我想说的是，随着职业生涯的发展，不知道某些事情是完全没问题的，
and to level with level with clients or supervisors, you know, or whoever you're working with. Actually, I'm not sure. You know, I was tempted to wing it there. But yeah, I don't know the answer. And I did that as recently as last week. I said to a client, well, I'm not quite sure about that that's not cropped up for me before but let's think about what that would mean to you and let's think about how we could come up with a plan that feels like it would be you know robust enough and at the end I said well how did
你可以向客户或主管坦诚。实际上，我确实有几次想蒙混过关，但我不知道答案。就在上周，我对一位客户说：“我不太确定，这之前没遇到过，但让我们想想这对你意味着什么，让我们想想如何制定一个足够稳健的计划。”最后我问：“当我承认我不知道、这之前没遇到过、我以前没这样用过这个资源时，你感觉如何？”
it feel when I said that I didn't really I don't really know this hadn't cropped up before I hadn't used this particular resource in this way with a client before. And so we'd need to kind of create that for ourselves. And, you know, the client said, well, you know, it is what it is, you know, it's, I wouldn't want you to be lying, you know, and just, you know, trying to look like you're winging it. It's okay. And because, you know, because people are bespoke, there cannot be one one size fits all. So, yeah, even today someone spoke to me about an honour, honour, I can't even say it, an honour. I'm going to leave this in as well. I'm going to leave this in the podcast edit so that you realise that I am human.
客户说：“没关系，就是这样。我不希望你撒谎，或者假装你知道。这没关系。”因为人是独特的，不可能有一种万能的方法。所以，即使是今天，有人跟我谈论一个“荣誉酬金”（honorarium）——我甚至说不出来，荣誉酬金。我会把这段保留在播客剪辑里，让你意识到我是人类。
An honorarium. And they started then launching off to thinking about this honorarium. And I said, I'm sorry, but I don't know what an honorarium is. You know, I imagine it means it's kind of free-ish, but yeah, you're gonna have to fill me in there. So yeah, then she had to tell me what an honorarium is. Yeah, Google it. So what did I do literally minutes after getting my first assistant post? Well, you know, to begin with, I was by myself, you know, I was in my partner at times flat and I was by myself and I just felt like, amazing. And I waited for him to get home and he said, oh, how did did it go how did the interview go and I said oh I didn't get the job I got a different one yay um because um yeah there was
荣誉酬金。他们开始谈论这个酬金，我说：“抱歉，我不知道什么是荣誉酬金。”我想它大概意味着是免费的，但你得告诉我。所以她不得不告诉我什么是荣誉酬金。是的，去谷歌一下吧。那么，我在拿到第一份助理职位后的几分钟内做了什么？起初，我独自一人，在伴侣的公寓里，我感觉太棒了。我等他回家，他说：“面试怎么样？”我说：“我没得到那份工作，但我得到了另一份，耶！”因为当时只招聘一个职位，我没得到那个，但他们喜欢我，说还有另一个职位即将空缺，他们想要我。
one job advertised I didn't get that job but they liked me and said that actually there's another job coming up and they'd like me for that one so um that's how that worked so um yeah and we just you know i just felt really really happy really really excited and you know ready for this next step of my of my journey um towards being what for me was a clinical psychologist but i appreciate that you might be listening to this as an aspiring sports psychologist or, you know, forensic or health or counselling, occupational, educational, so many lovely directions your career can take. So I hope that this is relevant and I welcome any feedback. You know, if you feel like actually the way I talk about things isn't relevant for your particular discipline.
这就是事情的经过。我感到非常非常开心，非常兴奋，准备好迎接我旅程的下一步，对我来说是成为临床心理学家。但我理解你可能是一名准运动心理学家，或者法医、健康、咨询、职业、教育心理学家，你的职业方向有太多美好的可能。所以我希望这与你相关，我欢迎任何反馈。如果你觉得我谈论的方式与你的特定学科不相关，
Give me a shout and let me know because I want this to be, you know, useful for all aspiring psychologists. That's the plan. Of course, I'm going to speak most convincingly about clinical psychology because, of course, that's what I've done. And that's my experience. experience but I hope that all of you listening regardless of what your own discipline is that you find there is a reason to stick around and to hang about okay we're gonna take a short break here and I'll be back to talk to you about growing into those relevant experience shoes speak to you soon shoes. Speak to you soon. fight so come and take a look it's right here in this book it's the clinical psychologist collective it's the clinical psychologist collective Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh psychologists. They offer their advice, hope and encouragement to aspiring clinical psychologists.
请告诉我，因为我希望这对所有准心理学家都有用。这就是我的计划。当然，我谈论临床心理学最令人信服，因为那是我的经历。但我希望所有听众，无论你的学科是什么，都能找到留下来听下去的理由。好了，我们要在这里休息一下，回来后我会谈谈如何适应那些“相关经验”的鞋子。很快回来。快来看看，就在这本书里，《临床心理学家集体》。哦，心理学家们。他们为准临床心理学家提供建议、希望和鼓励。
This book helps to put in perspective the variety of journeys people take to become qualified. I would recommend this book to anyone interested in, then let this be your guide. Filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective Oh
这本书有助于从不同角度看待人们成为合格心理学家的各种旅程。我会向任何感兴趣的人推荐这本书，让它成为你的指南。书中充满了经验教训，将帮助你获得资格。所以来看看吧，就在这本书里，《临床心理学家集体》。
Oh oh honestly is it just me who could listen to my jingle guy's voice all day sometimes it's gonna move me to tears it's just lovely so yeah i hope you love having these jingles in your head because i i sing them i sing them constantly So my first assistant post, honestly, I did not know I was born. I had my own office that I shared with my colleague. And, you know, I was in private practice. And so there was the stationary budget was limitless. And so we were given the stationary catalogue and, you know know invited to flick through it and order what we wanted basically so we had a nice spongy sort of wrist support mouse mat and a wrist support thing for the keyboard and you know a desk tidy
老实说，难道只有我一个人能整天听我那个叮当声小哥的声音吗？有时它会让我热泪盈眶，真是太可爱了。所以我希望你喜欢这些在脑海中回荡的叮当声，因为我一直在唱它们。关于我的第一份助理工作，老实说，我当时真是太幸福了。我有自己的办公室，和同事共用。我在私人诊所工作，文具预算是无限的。我们拿到了文具目录，可以随意翻阅并订购我们想要的东西。我们有舒适的海绵腕托鼠标垫、键盘腕托，还有桌面整理架。
you know and when I compare that to when I worked in the NHS as an assistant I didn't even have my own desk and I did some sessions in a cupboard. And then when I was qualified, everyone loves agile working, right? You know, I didn't have a chair. You know, I really didn't know I was born. So if you find that you've got like a really good setup and you've got your own chair, celebrate that, you know tag me in on linkedin celebrate your own chair put put a sign on it you know saying your name and your chair spin around on it do your own office chair olympics you know yeah you've got your own chair you've made it in life um so yeah that's certainly more than i've had across my career at times but you know we are able to bring out a game regardless of our settings, hopefully. But yeah, agile working is an ace for me.
当我把它与我在NHS做助理时相比，我甚至没有自己的办公桌，有些咨询是在储藏室里进行的。后来我合格了，每个人都喜欢“敏捷办公”，对吧？我连椅子都没有。我当时真是太幸福了。所以如果你发现你的配置很好，有自己的椅子，那就庆祝一下吧。在LinkedIn上标记我，庆祝你拥有自己的椅子，在上面贴上你的名字，在上面转圈，举办你自己的办公椅奥运会。是的，你拥有自己的椅子，你的人生成功了。这确实比我职业生涯中某些时候拥有的要多，但希望无论环境如何，我们都能发挥出最佳水平。
You know, I remember when I was working at Argos head office, I kind of had those little baffle boards around my desk. And I had pictures of when I'd been away traveling to be able to look on when times felt hard. So I like, you know, I like having nice things to look at. I like having pictures that feel significant, that feel important. So, yeah, I think I definitely operate best with my own space that's mine. I don't have to sanitize the keyboard, you know, so that's that's that's where I will operate optimally for me. But if you're currently having your own agile working challenges, then I hear you. So when I got my first qualified post, it had been off the back of the recession that was happening at the time.
记得我在Argos总部工作时，办公桌周围有那种小隔板。我放了一些旅行时的照片，以便在困难时期看一看。我喜欢看美好的事物，喜欢放一些有意义、重要的照片。所以我认为我在属于自己的空间里工作效率最高。我不必去消毒键盘，那是我能发挥最佳水平的地方。但如果你目前正面临敏捷办公的挑战，我理解你。当我获得第一份合格职位时，正值当时的经济衰退之后。
And there were very, very few jobs. And at that time, places on clinical training were reducing not mid cohort or anything that would be catastrophic you are the weakest link goodbye oh it wasn't like that but you know suddenly we were a cohort 15 and then the year after us were 17 and the year after that I think went down It might have been 15 again, or it might have been below that. But I think at one point they had a cohort of 10, which is very different to a cohort been to a fair few interviews but I had no job to go to and actually I found that I kept getting pipped to the post by people that had already been qualified for a few years and you know I was I was good enough at that time as a newly qualified band seven but it's very hard to compete with somebody who you know might be stepping down from
工作岗位非常非常少。当时，临床培训的名额正在减少，不是那种灾难性的“你是最弱的一环，再见”，不是那样的。但突然间，我们这一届是15人，第二年是17人，再后来我记得降到了15人，或者更少。我想有一次他们只有10人的名额，这与之前完全不同。我参加过不少面试，但没有工作可去。我发现自己总是被那些已经合格几年的人挤掉。作为一名刚合格的七级（Band 7）心理学家，我当时足够优秀，但很难与那些可能从更高职位降下来做七级工作的人，或者任何有经验的合格心理学家竞争。因为我当然是刚从临床博士学位毕业的。
an AA to come and do band seven or, you know, to compete with any qualified psychologist that had been doing it for a while. Because I was, of course, fresh off my clinical doctorate boat. And so, yeah, that's, I just found that I kept losing out until I didn't, you know, until I got my first qualified post. And at that point, yeah, I had a little bit of downtime. So I finished in September. Then I had October off and November off. And I think at some point in November, I knew I was going to be starting.
所以，我一直处于劣势，直到我最终得到了第一份合格职位。那时，我有一段空档期。我在九月结束了学业，十月和十一月休息。我想在十一月的某个时候，我知道我即将开始工作。
And so at the beginning of December, I did start my job. And yeah, I had a little bit of time, you know, eating lots of things with lentils in to try and make the money go further and drawing on my savings a bit as much as possible. And also, you know, my partner, partner, who's now my husband, wasn't going to see me destitute and out on the street, because that would have meant he was on the street as well. So, you know, just had to get through it. Because, of course, what we know about certainly about the clinical doctorate is that it's a period of training contracts so long as you meet those milestones and you get there and you know you do what you're supposed to be doing then with any luck you will become a qualified
十二月初，我开始了工作。我有一点时间，吃了很多扁豆做的食物来节省开支，尽可能动用我的积蓄。而且，我的伴侣——现在是我的丈夫——不会看着我陷入困境流落街头，因为那意味着他也会流落街头。所以，我们必须熬过去。因为我们知道，临床博士学位是一段培训合同期，只要你达到那些里程碑，做到你应该做的事，那么运气好的话，你就会成为一名合格的心理学家。
psychologist but there is no guarantee of a job and that was absolutely allowed you know around loud and clear when I was qualifying in 2011 so So there will be an ebb and a flow, you know, sometimes there will be more jobs and sometimes there will be less. But yeah, happily, I was able to start work in the tail end of 2011 in time to get paid for Christmas, which is always really nice. But what I like about this time off between jobs is that ability to reflect and to consolidate and to allow myself to transition to this next step, this next stage, because they are significant and they matter. And, you know, I just like a little bit of pause and, you know, what we talk about is rest and digest, you know, just, you know, just do a bit less,
但没有任何工作保证，这在我2011年获得资格时是非常明确的。所以，工作会有起伏，有时岗位多，有时岗位少。但幸运的是，我能够在2011年底开始工作，赶上圣诞节发工资，这总是很棒的。但我喜欢这段工作间隙的休息时间，因为它让我能够反思、巩固，并让自己过渡到下一个阶段，因为这些阶段很重要。我喜欢一点点停顿，我们谈论的是“休息和消化”，少做一点，
you know, breathe a bit more. If that was now, I'd be probably going out for runs and stuff more. I think I was less fixated on any kind of exercise at the time, probably doing Pilates and things like that. But yeah, I would now I'm a mummy. I'm super good at using time off, you know, there weren't kid gloves and I thought I needed kid gloves. I thought I needed, you know, when you are newly qualified, you know, you can have to like, you know, work up to doing X, Y and Z. And, you know, there wasn't that, you know, it's like, well, you are a qualified psychologist, you are the real deal, you know, you've earned your stripes, now go. But it wasn't like my caseload built as a flood immediately that bit um you know trickled in in a gradual predictable way um but yeah there wasn't that period of you
多呼吸一点。如果是现在，我可能会更多地去跑步。当时我不太关注任何运动，可能只是做做普拉提之类的。但现在我当了妈妈，我非常擅长利用休息时间。当时没有“儿童手套”，我以为我需要。我以为当我刚合格时，我需要慢慢适应去做X、Y和Z。但并没有那样，你是一名合格的心理学家，你是真正的专业人士，你已经赢得了你的勋章，现在出发吧。但我的病例量并没有立即像洪水一样涌来，而是以一种渐进的、可预测的方式慢慢增加。
know oh you know just see how you go get used to making decisions you know get used to doing that and being part of the team you know sometimes i was just sent to kind of, you know, be in a meeting as the psychologist in the team. Do you know what I mean? It wasn't like I was shadowing a proper psychologist who knew what they were doing. You know, I was it. And that was actually really helpful for me. It didn't feel like being chucked into deep water. It felt like someone was believing in me. And so bear that in mind if you find that you're feeling a bit floundery, you know, maybe it's actually a mark of someone's confidence in your ability to do that job. But if you feel like things are overwhelming, always shout out about that. As I said before, my, you know, I like to mark occasions and chapters with wardrobe. So I definitely had a qualified psychologist wardrobe and I was forever gutted that my favorite I'm a qualified psychologist dress got a hole ripped in it by my NHS lanyard which made me really sad because I loved that dress and it just wasn't repairable you know where the hole was it just wasn't repairable so look after your favorite
没有那种“哦，看看你表现如何，习惯做决定，习惯成为团队一部分”的时期。有时我只是被派去作为团队中的心理学家参加会议。你明白我的意思吗？并不是我在跟随一位真正知道自己在做什么的心理学家。我就是那个人。这对我来说实际上非常有帮助。这感觉不像被扔进深水区，而感觉像是有人相信我。所以如果你感到有点迷茫，请记住这一点，也许这正是别人对你胜任这份工作充满信心的标志。但如果你觉得事情太令人不知所措，一定要大声说出来。正如我之前所说，我喜欢用衣橱来标记场合和章节。我确实有一个“合格心理学家衣橱”，我一直很遗憾我最喜欢的“我是合格心理学家”连衣裙被我的NHS挂绳扯破了一个洞，这让我很难过，因为我喜欢那条裙子，而且那个洞没法修补。所以要照顾好你最喜欢的
I'm a assistant psychologist or I'm a research assistant psychologist outfits because NHS lanyards don't always like them. So as I said, I love celebrating your successes. So please do come and connect with me on socials. I am really easy to find on certainly LinkedIn. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent. Tag me in or, you know, some other way. Let me know about this post and I will help you celebrate because it's big and it's important. And well done you.
“我是助理心理学家”或“我是研究助理心理学家”的服装，因为NHS挂绳并不总是对它们友好。正如我所说，我喜欢庆祝你的成功。所以请在社交媒体上与我联系。在LinkedIn上找到我非常容易，我是Dr. Marianne Trent。标记我，或者用其他方式告诉我这个职位，我会帮你庆祝，因为这很重要。做得好。
If you are listening on YouTube, then please subscribe and like and comment and click that little notification bell to be told when I produce more content. My kids told me to say that they spend a lot of their time watching YouTube. They love it. And I said, Mommy, you've got to start asking people to click the notification bell. So there you go, kids. Mommy's done it. They also want me to have merch. We were shopping with my eldest a few months ago and there was a shopping list and on the back of it was like a picture of the Grief Collective book. And my eldest was like, mummy, quick, stick it on your back and call it merch. It really made me laugh. And I was like, well, no, because then I won't know what I need to buy. And I also look very silly. So, yeah, no plans to launch any merch coming soon, guys. But yeah, subscribe, like, you know, tell your friends, do all those lovely things to help me
如果你是在YouTube上收听，请订阅、点赞、评论并点击那个小铃铛图标，以便在我制作更多内容时收到通知。我的孩子们让我这么说，他们花很多时间看YouTube，他们很喜欢。我说：“妈妈，你得开始让人们点击通知铃铛。”所以，孩子们，妈妈做到了。他们还希望我有周边商品。几个月前我和大孩子去购物，有一个购物清单，背面是《悲伤集体》书的图片。大孩子说：“妈妈，快，把它贴在背上，叫它周边。”这真的让我笑了。我说：“不行，那样我就不知道我需要买什么了，而且看起来很傻。”所以，目前没有推出周边商品的计划。但请订阅、点赞，告诉你的朋友，做所有那些可爱的举动来帮助我
to be able to create and continue to create this hopefully useful quality content for you as an aspiring psychologist, whatever the stage of your journey you are at. Thank you so much for listening and I will look forward to catching up with you very soon. Take care. guide. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist podcast with Dr. Marianne Durant. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing
能够继续为你创作这些有用的高质量内容，无论你作为准心理学家处于旅程的哪个阶段。非常感谢你的收听，我期待很快与你再次交流。保重。指南。有这个播客在身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是《准心理学家播客》，我是Marianne Trent博士。我叫Jana，是一名心理健康实习医生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于通往目标的各种不同途径非常有趣，成为心理学家没有完美的途径，这让我充满信心，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
做错了，对自己少一点压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐你这样做，让自己放轻松，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读这本书，你就不会想把它放下。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。